Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So I recently discovered this box full of
childhood memorabilia.
It hasn't been explored in at least 10 years,
and today we're going to find out what's inside.
The first thing I notice when I open the box
is this participant badge to a science and
engineering fair.
I didn't finish first, I didn't finish second,
or third, but I did participate.
Hank, the fact that mom and dad chose to keep
my participant ribbon perhaps indicates why
you're the brother who deconstructed an adding
machine.
Here I have a "mom and dad why did you ever
let me buy those glasses?"
picture.
Photograph of me from my brief experimentation
with contact lenses.
And a picture of me from back when I was the
worst player on my childhood soccer team.
Alright what else?
Oh Hank look!
Academic Decathlon Medals.
So Hank it looks like the rest of this box
contains boxes.
When I was a kid I had a, uh, box collection?
And by "when I was a kid" I mean until my
early twenties.
Anyway, lets see if the boxes have anything
in them.
This is a lovely box given to me by my college
girlfriend.
It's empty, that's a metaphor.
This ones a winner.
Oh and there's stuff inside!
But sadly it's just more boxes.
Empty box.
Another empty box.
What childhood memories did you preserve John?
Oh, I preserved memories of emptiness.
This box actually has something in it; it
is a rose given to me by Betsy Hinckle, my
tenth-grade home-coming dance date.
Oh my god there is also a tooth in there!
It is one of my baby teeth Hank, or at any
rate, someone's baby teeth.
This box had some of my old cub scout patches
in it from 1985.
This box had a stamp from Germany inside of
it.
Glad I chose to keep that.
This one's empty.
This one I can't figure out how to open, that's
kind of exciting.
GAHHH!
It's empty.
This box just has a bunch of pennies in it.
I don't know why I chose to keep them.
You shouldn't even exist pennies!
I know what you're wondering Hank, what's
in this box?
You will never guess, unless you guessed boxes.
Alright Hank, last box, my most beloved box
from childhood -- this real cigar box, let's
see what's inside.
Oh, there's pictures.
There is actually something of value in here!
These are not pictures of me.
These are mostly picture of flowers.
Flower, flower...
No!
Oh, there's me, What am I doing?
Am I eating a snake?
That's the one Hank, that's the one picture
of me I chose to keep.
Hank, down at the bottom beneath all of the
boxes, was this beautiful book, "Baby's milestones,
birth to seven years" filled out by our mom
and dad.
There is like a little bracelet that Mom wore
at the hospital.
Polaroid pictures of me just after birth.
Here are my foot prints, and here on this
page, Hank, preserved for all time my Mom
and Dad's first words about me my Mother said
"He's ugly" exclamation point.
And my Dad said, "He's so purple" exclamation
point.
Ah, to be fair I have seen a few newborns
in my day.
They do tend towards the ugly and the purple.
So Hank, what have we learned from this trip
down memory lane?
Two things I think, first, put things in your
boxes.
And secondly life is not so much about things
as it is about people, and what we do together.
Hank, the amazing thing about that box of
childhood memories is that you could go through
the whole thing without ever knowing I had
a brother.
And yet nonetheless it is completely impossible
for me to imagine my life without you, you
adding-machine deconstructing nerd.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.